you know i hate having to do a
correction here but this is the kind of
show that we run i made a mistake we
actually get three times the demo of ari
melbourne's show not two but three and i
regret making that error i apologize and
i won't let you guys down ever again all
right
do you think you're stupid if you
haven't been shot by cupid this poll
says you're a victim of hate if you
haven't yet found a mate yeah just in
time to make singles feel bad before
valentine's day a new survey seeks to
answer the question are single people
more discriminated against than couples
the yougov poll of a thousand americans
highlights singlism which describes the
hardship of being unmarried specifically
laws policies or practices that favor
couples for example married people often
pay less in taxes and benefit more from
social security and not to mention
lotion
survey participants were asked whether
single people are stigmatized
and discriminated against 42 percent
said yeah 40 said no and the other 20
couldn't get reception in their basement
apartments cat yep you've been married
for uh
eight weeks
so you remember being single and now
that you're married what do you do you
feel that when you you were
discriminated against and you're less
discriminated against now yes yes right
like food delivery apps like you can
never meet the minimum if it's just you
that's true like all these different
things and then if you're single
everyone's like what's wrong with you
like are you you're not marriage
material but nobody says that about me
anymore now that i'm married even though
i'm still not marriage material
so true
uh will would i hate you know why i hate
married people and i am one no i don't
hate married people i hate married
people with kids because they have
because they have excuses for everything
it's like oh i can't little billy has
head lice
oh you know
a little but if you're single you can't
say you don't have anything to like
write off your hangover on you just get
hardened in course yes and you just say
no
right i bet you just said no do you
wanna do this no yeah and i have to come
up with i don't have to i have the
excuses soccer game yeah whatever we
gotta get to it's always posted on more
game it's not even a sport
what oh
it's gonna hurt a lot of little boys in
texas right now i hope they're not
watching my daughter's got practice
right now you've got to watch it gut
fell yeah
that's why i said it because she's not
it's okay to discriminate against
singles by the way it's a why why
because you should get married and start
a family oh shut up
you should
you should you should shut up
[Laughter]
you should start a family oh my god okay
all right i thank you for letting me
know what i should do with my uterus i'm
here
i'm here for you for the full show
so anyway what i like about this story
greg
is we are now creating isms right this
is singleism out of essentially family
feud polls survey says singlism that's
so true yeah this was like a really easy
poll today it was like 40 40 20. i'm not
sure that really was definitive on
whether this is an issue or not i think
it is an issue because bye for one tyrus
i i when i go to the movies alone
uh i people i just feel very
self-conscious and i mean especially if
you're masturbating
the um
i'm not saying i'm just saying for
single people what the hell is your
question you little creep
what are you all right peewee what's
your question my question is do you
believe that there's such thing as
singlism
only when uh a single friend asked me
for a loan and i'm like you got no kids
you got no wife you you why are you
broke like what are you doing with
yourself spend it on vices to fill the
hole in your heart that would
end up it isn't excuses raising your
children albeit i went about it a
different route
decided to have children first and kind
of do the marriage thing on the back end
but that's
neither here nor there it's all together
now and one judging one big disgruntled
baby mama family but
you make it work you need to have your
awards you need to have head according
to the court
the point is is like
whenever a single person is whiny to a
married
couple with children of course we hate
them yes like you have no idea you've
never had to
do the quickie in five seconds in the
closet so they won't find you you never
they always want to sleep in the room
with you they're always around you
everything they do when you have
something nice you end up with
fingerprints on it and goo and glitter
so yeah when a single person's like oh
my god i'm so just shut up just go away
you have no idea also they also the
single people just have an endless
supply of sleep and energy yes yes and
choices and choices
you know what i think we've changed your
mind well
a school compares sex to pepperoni and
parrots respond with acrimony hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else